ce n'est vraiment pas évident de rester
financièrement veine cette année vous le
savez on parle beaucoup des os des
baisses des marchés boursiers pour en
discuter on avec nous aujourd'hui marc
st-pierre gestionnaire de portefeuille
une partager quelques trucs aujourd'hui
bonjour monsieur saint pierre je veux
club donc vous avez écrit récemment un
livre quarante cinq conseils pour mettre
votre argent au travail quels conseils
donnez vous aux gens pour tenter de se
dire est ce qu'on doit se départir de
ses actifs par exemple en ce moment il y
en a beaucoup qui sont peut-être tenté
dans un premier temps on voulait
s'inscrire en faux contre ce qu'ils
avaient dans l'industrie haut on vous
laisse miroiter des titres du style
investi en bourse est devenu
millionnaire c'est parce qu'on voulait
oui c'est comme dit courait le 100 m en
9 secondes et gagné deux médailles
olympiques ça pas d'abus alors ce qu'on
a voulu faire c'est départager d'aller à
la base qui est important c'est de se
donner un plat match l'important c'est
de commencer relativement jeune investir
et ce qui est le plus important c'est de
rester disciplinés et c'est là qu'est le
problème c'est ça qui est difficile en
ce moment en théorie en théorie à long
terme la bourse surperforment les
occases actifs sauf que humainement on
le voit on voit 2022 où on a des reculs
de marché même aujourd'hui et là les
gens se questionnent et quand on se met
à sera questionné le danger c'est de
prendre de mauvaises décisions
mon conseil aujourd'hui n'ouvrez pas
votre enveloppe qui contient votre revue
v pour le mois de juin six ans quand une
application pour regarder leur
portefeuille tous les jours mares dg des
clients geagea des clients et ils n'ont
pas accès à leurs portefeuilles sur
l'internet il faut qu'ils m'appellent je
regarde le portefeuille et la pression
en conversation et ailleurs est ce que
ça vous appelle beaucoup parlé tactique
aux abeilles sinon parce qu'ils sont
habitués parce qu'on a établi entre le
problème qu'on a en investissements ce
qu'on a tendance à regarder
et le rendement récents on se place à la
fin rappelez vous fin 2021 qu'elle année
exceptionnelle est bien là 25 % pour les
actions canadiennes 28 pour le wiiware
etc et les gens voulaient à cette époque
là je sais on me disait ben on devrait
être revoir des obligations c'est un peu
périlleux des taux monte on va peut être
l'argent pourquoi qu'on n'augmente pas
la pondération d'action est rare et faut
se donner un plan de match on entend
tout le monde que vous racontiez
quelqu'un un conseiller que ce soit un
spécialiste que ce soit un planificateur
dans une édition financière ou quelqu'un
qui est indépendant on va vous parler
quoi de diversification de répartition
d'actifs et de ré et qu'il avait écrit à
rééquilibrer le portefeuille donc
aujourd'hui moi je dis on fait rien ben
on fait rien c'est à dire il faut éviter
de paniquer on se retrouve aujourd'hui
avec une convention qui est le marché
boursier et tu as quand il est moins
cher qu'il était en début d'année les
taux d'intérêt qui étaient extrêmement
bons en début d'année sont maintenant
robert m'a remonté quelques belles
opportunités les occasions par l'iodé
occasionne est l'occasion mais il reste
qu'il faut probablement pour la plupart
être prudent est-ce qu'il faut revoir sa
coopération il y en ait commencent à
critiquer le 60% 540% obligations qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
historiquement ce genre quand on parle
le fameux 60 40 qui est 40 % en
obligations à 60% en actions
historiquement on regarde ce que ça a
donné les obligations vous ont donné des
lendemains de 3 4% les actions vous a
donné un rendement de 8 donc au total un
portefeuille et à 40 % d'obligations et
60 en actions vous a donné des
rendements de 5 à 6% sans prendre de
risque les obligations ne sont pas très
intéressants part sombre ils sont pas
intéressantes parce que les taux
d'intérêt sont met à remonter donc les
obligations perdu de la valeur sauf
qu'aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui veut placer
dans un certificat de placement d'un an
ou deux ans les taux sont à 4 pour ça
donc se tourner vers sent d'ailleurs à
partie pour ceux qui ceux qui n'ont pas
aimé la personne calmes qu'à sa baisse à
quand on fait des profils de risque on
demande bien comment vous vous sentez
mais on sent bien quand ça monte puis on
sent très mal quand ça baisse et quand
ça monte on veut un réseau et quand ça
belge jean van hamme mais à éviter
il y en a peut-être qui se rendent
compte par contre qu'ils ont mal évalué
leur tolérance au risque c'est facile de
dire je suis pas stressé avec les
marchés est ce que vous en voyez qu'ils
s'étaient trompés c'est ce qu'il faut
faire c'est sûr et asseoir midi mais
voilà ce que j'ai aujourd'hui par ma
peau j'ai regardé les premiers sept mois
de l'année pour regarder la dernière
année de regarder un dernier 5 ans 10
ans puis voir un peu qu'est ce que ça a
donné comme rendement est ce que c'est
allah était à la hauteur du calcul qui
était fait peut-être on parle de
planification quand un régime de
retraite qu'est ce qu'ils font l'actu
boudiba pour rencontrer les engagements
du régime s'en prend 6% de rendement 6%
vraiment comment je l'obtiens dont on
fait de répartition d'actif souvent pour
les individus c'est pas comme ça qu'on
raisonne on regarde notre portefeuille
pons abécistes épouvantables sans
prendre en considération le but premier
de cette répartition d'actif le pourvoir
à long terme faut voir à long terme par
contre j'ai déjà dit à quelqu'un si
votre portefeuille vous empêche de
dormir changez votre portefeuille si
vous dormez poche pour comme ils jouent
en ligne on peut s'empêcher dormait mada
promesses une question de temps avant
que ça devienne problématique mais c'est
vraiment on a sous-estimé
nous créons notre réaction aux baisses
de marché faut peut être voir notre part
pour avoir un faut s'asseoir avec un
planificateur avec un conseiller en
relations d'affaires et et et d'éviter
de faire ce que bon des biens des gens
font c'est à dire de dit ben voilà ça
c'est différent cette fois-ci on va se
retrouver que l'inflation comme dans les
années 70 puis des banques centrales
vont monter les taux c'est avec ses
draps et puis l'heure ben y'a pas un
écrin la panique près l'on parle de
récession le mois à air pour faire bien
attention sur la danse nationale à toi
jeudi ces quatre veaux oui mais facile à
dire c'est peut-être même si la fa et
même pour nous comme gestionnaire de
portefeuille personnel saison tout le
monde se pose exactement le transpose
mois
dans la peau de mon client ma cliente
puis je comprends ta main ce qu'ils
vivent alors faut essayer de d'éviter
des erreurs parce que de toute façon à
long terme à long terme depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale une douzaine de
récession les périodes de récession ça
dure à peu près onze mois en moyenne
dans kung fu est on passe plus de temps
à période de croissance qu en période de
ralentissement ou de récession et la
bouche sur de longues périodes de temps
75% des années à des rendements positifs
donc faut garder des actions en
portefeuille
et quand on voit des sites qui balisent
comme ça oui excusez moi on va devoir
s'acquitter je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir été le cheval est encore une
fois on voit que vous aimez votre métier
merci de pouvoir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]